[Music]
sweet
[Applause]
are we in mexico
twelve dollars was like i just got one
then
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so we landed in tokyo now do a
toast
cheers
[Music]
that's crazy huh his first ever summer
train experience
[Music]
i'm so excited for you to
[Music]
today we are at the airport to go to
paris
are you crying
[Music]
growing up my entire life i always
constantly would wish i could like turn
back time and change my past
whatever i went through in life and
meeting you really showed me that i
needed to go through everything i went
through because it led me to you we're
going off to barcelona on our honeymoon
oh my god
this is so cool we got a jacuzzi inside
the room
oh this is so cool
[Music]
[Music]
cheers
[Music]
oh this is huh heavy wow that's what it
really looks like inside oh not so fun
the sun's not always set yet
i just flew into croatia you can
good life
[Music]
oh my gosh
[Music]
all right we're eating breakfast hong
kong breakfast at a
[Music]
oh fresh out the oven
[Music]
look baby we're in iceland
[Music]
oh my gosh baby you look so good
[Music]
we were served by a celebrity
like the best dumpling you've ever had
in your
in your mouth we're moving in we're
moving in we are homeowners
you're about to enter the house as
homeowners now for the first time
[Music]
oh my god i'm so excited now that we're
actually inside
[Music]
three
two
one
[Music]
[Music]
you